[Musica]
allora amedeo abbiamo detto per me un
significato particolare quando così ci
siamo trovati per parlare un po di cosa
avrebbe potuto dire tu volevi mettere
una canzone che è le radici ca tieni e
io arrivo proprio a questo tema delle
radici ma soprattutto il tema della casa
e allora ti chiedo cos'è per te la casa
per me la casa è innanzitutto luogo
fisico quindi sono le radici sono il
luogo che da cui tutto parte è il luogo
dove intanto ospita un nucleo familiare
è il luogo dei ricordi e luogo nei primi
amore il logo delle prime esperienze e
luogo dell'anima altresì la casa per me
è anche la visione futura ovvero è
quello che mi ha portato ad essere oggi
qual è quello che ha alimentato i miei
sogni hanno fatto sì che questi
diventino realtà
per me va a casa è diventata vita quindi
tutto quello che c'è di mezzo fra fra
radici e futuro e fra
[Musica]
a fra quello che appunto qualcosa di
reale di concreto e uno stato ormai un
vero e proprio stato del del pensiero
nostante la mente uno stato di se stesso
una sola parola cosa per me casa per me
casa è proprio il primo luogo dove siete
stesso il luogo dove ti ritrovi il luogo
dove sei te e da solo nel senso sei
veramente te stesso sei quello che
vorresti essere nella costruzione della
tua casa c'è qualcosa che è stato
ovviamente fondamentale ed è stata la
musica
allora cosa è stata la musica nella
costruzione della tua casa e cos'è la
musica nella tua vita è per me la musica
e la vita la musica e quello che come
hai detto tu prima e arrivo dalla
provincia di benevento e come tutti
sapete bene penso che tutti la conoscono
perché oltre ad essere l'ultima in
campionato è anche una delle città forse
più povere d'italia
la musica è quello che mi ha salvato
perché io vengo da un paesino in
provincia di benevento dove era tutto
difficile dove la musica era l'unica
cosa che riusciva a tenere vivo i miei
sogni era quello che alimentava la mia
passione era quello che mi faceva salire
sui treni
mi faccia nascondere nei bagni dei treni
per andare ad assistere concerti un po
in giro tutta italia
la musica è quello che ha spinto i miei
studi la musica è quello che mi ha
portato a vivere a new york
e per uno che arriva da tocco caudio in
provincia di benevento capite per
arrivare a new york era la conditio sine
qua non è di una vita bellissima di un
sogno realizzato
e invece a new york succede che appunto
la musica mi mi fa dire no ai miei
genitori mi fa dire no quest'anno non
torni a casa decide di restare a new
york perché il 31 dicembre ci sarebbe
stato nel 2006 un concerto di james
brown james brown a new york alla pollo
theatre quando mi sarebbe più ricapitata
un tocco caudio resto qua mamma fa in
meno da mangiare però mi dispiace se
james brown che suona new york james
brown purtroppo muore il 25 dicembre e
quindi io l'unica cosa che mi sento di
fare di andare praticamente ai funerali
che avrebbero fatto alla polizia per il
29 dicembre quando entrò l'apologia
terra vedo james brown
una sorta di illuminazione ho capito che
forse stavo sbagliando e ho detto no
devo tornare devo devo provare a vivere
di musica grazie a james brown tordo in
italia e e creò la mia casa creolo e da
lì poi è partito un po tutto con tutti i
sacrifici e con tutto quello che ad oggi
le persone vedono ma che pochi conoscono
adesso sai che vorrei farti una domanda
che è un po delicata ed è una domanda
che si enuclea con due date la prima è
la sera del 13 novembre 2015
siamo a parigi e in questa sera 130
persone 130 innocenti vengono a mancare
vengono a mancare perché il terrorismo
va a colpirle va ad uccidere va a
distruggere fuori da uno stadio in un
ristorante e in un club in cui c'era un
concerto quel concerto era tenuto dagli
eagles of death metal e la seconda data
che io voglio così proporti è il 6
settembre 2016
perché il 6 settembre 2016 perché nel
tuo festival un festival gli eagles of
death metal cioè quel gruppo che era
presente quando è successo quello che
sappiamo al bataclan
hanno suonato e io immagino cosa può
essere stato per te il giorno della
strage una persona che lavora per creare
gioia per creare aggregazione cosa hai
provato cosa è stato quando hai visto
che il terrorismo andava proprio a
colpire quello che era il cuore del tuo
lavoro il cuore delle tue passioni
allora la c'è stata intanto nazione
abbiamo voluto io e tutti i ragazzi che
lavorano con me abbiamo voluto
fortemente gigolo death metal proprio
per lanciare un segnale contro il
terrorismo
io quella sera tra l'altro ero al
concerto dei foo fighters a cesena un
momento storico per chi fa musica e
perché vi vede musica perché mille pazzi
mila appassionati mille musicisti
appassionati hanno girato un video dove
loro suonavano imitando uno dei gruppi
più famosi del mondo a suonare a cesena
il gruppo aveva detto sì è quella sera
appunto suonavano a cesena e noi eravamo
pieni di entusiasmo pieni di gioia
perché appunto il giorno dopo poi
saremmo andati a torino concetto che poi
fu annullato proprio per quello che era
successo a parigi e quindi è stato
qualcosa già di per sé toccante perché
stiamo parlando una strage stiamo
parlando di una tragedia che ha toccato
forse delle persone che stavano un mi
rendo lo stesso momento che io vivevo
quella sera soltanto loro hanno avuto la
sfortuna di trovarsi nella città
sbagliata e quindi lo sgomento abbiamo
tradotto in cose in un sorriso nel senso
che l'unico modo che avevamo per far
capire per combattere quello che era il
terrorismo non era battersi non era
armarsi non era
[Musica]
andare a combattere il terrorismo ma era
nel miglior dei modi affrontarlo con un
sorriso affrontarlo con la musica è far
sì che la musica in questo caso proprio
quella di google del metal perché doveva
essere un segnale forte
lo stesso segnale che poi noi abbiamo
dato quest'anno perché dopo il concerto
di manchester nel concerto di avere una
grande noi il giorno dopo l'attentato
che c'è stata a manchester abbiamo
annunciato agli altri artisti
è un po come secondo me deve fare la
musica deve fare l'arte deve fare il
mondo per poi sconfiggere perché la
guerra non portava nient'altro che ed è
morta invece col sorriso con la passione
è l'unico modo che abbiamo per per
distruggere infatti a me cessare cosa è
successo dopo un po di settimane hanno
riorganizzato concerto ancora più grande
ancora con più persone e hanno vinto
hanno vinto perché quelle persone non
hanno avuto paura e della stessa cosa
che non abbiamo provato a fare il 7
settembre a far sì che le persone non
avessero paura ma che si divertissero
quest'anno è avuto un altro momento
abbastanza delicato quando per motivi di
sicurezza è dovuto anullare forse quella
che era la data più attesa del suo
festival e da una parte penso che sia
fare delle scelte impopolari su una cosa
molto rock
dall'altra però
la gestione che hai dovuto affrontare
dei social network che sei anche una
persona molto comunicativa molto esposta
è stata una cosa faticosa la vivo da
fuori con empatia però mi ha molto
colpito questa gestione di social
network come dover fare delle scelte
impopolari da una parte e come dover
gestire queste scelte quando si ha una
figura esposta cometa partiamo dal
presupposto che a prescindere
dell'esposizione quello che ho fatto io
è sempre metterci la faccia in tutto nel
senso che io mi sono sempre prese
responsabilità su tutto quello che vado
a fare dal momento in cui esce il primo
manifesto al momento in cui l'ultima
persona va a casa
non lo faremo in modo perfetto perché la
perfezione purtroppo a questo mondo non
esiste però deciso di farlo in modo vero
in modo reale e quella mattina
mi ricordo ancora noi eravamo erano ero
tornato a casa intorno alle 4 del
mattino e c'erano circa 40 persone
c'erano che lavoravano perché il giorno
dopo sarebbe dovuta appunto entrare una
produzione molto molto importante
verso le 6 circa del mattino mi chiama
uno dei miei migliori amici nonché il
mio avvocato e mi dice sto passando a
prenderti ho realizzato subito quello
che sta succedendo la mia prima domanda
è stata dimmi solo che non ci sono morti
e lui fanno lo so e quindi io sono
passato da casa mia fino al all'area
dove si svolge il concerto con con tutto
un patema d'animo perché pensavo il caso
più estremo appena rivola c'era uno dei
ragazzi che da sempre lavora a far sì
che che non festival si realizzi e
appena mi vede mi abbraccia scoppia a
piangere mi dice stavolta pensavo di non
vedere più mia figlia sua figlia circa
un anno e la ho capito quello che stava
succedendo e quindi preso poi da dal
momento di angoscia quando abbiamo
capito che alla fine contenute era fatto
male nessuno abbiamo deciso ho deciso in
quel momento capisce il momento
concitato tutti che vogliono avere delle
risposte tutti che che pretendono
qualcosa è la migliore cosa era dare la
risposta che ti da oggi è l'importante
in quel caso non si sia fatto male
nessuno cioè che quindi alla domanda ci
sono stati morti non ci sono stati morti
e quindi è vero che è stata una scelta
impopolare vero è stata una scelta in
cui ci siamo tirati dentro tantissimo
offesa anche sul personale quelli che mi
hanno toccato di più è stato uno che ha
detto dovete morire tutti e la guardia
che stava succedendo sul serio ma ancora
di più è stato uno
quando poi parli di dell'esposizione
mediatica che mi ha detto mi ha dato del
figlio di papà
beh io sono un figlio di papà io sono
figlio di un operaio mia mamma è
un'impiegata e sono loro poi che hanno
tenuto vivo i miei sogni e sono loro che
hanno fatto sì che poi lui non
diventasse quello che per alcuni versi
ha influenzato il panorama musicale
italiano influenzato spero positivamente
la città di treviso
oltretutto
io sono figlio di un padre che ha
imparato a metterci la faccia a guardare
le persone gli occhi a dire e così va da
purtroppo sbagliato ea quella persona mi
ricordo che ho risposto ho detto guarda
io almeno se voi non mi nascondo dietro
uno schermo sai chi sono
se vuoi possiamo parlarne ti racconto
quello che è stato per cui non ho mai
apprezzato che si nasconde dietro una
tastiera per cui è vero che l'era dello
storytelling e bello della keller ha in
cui dobbiamo raccontare qualcosa non più
vivere quelle delle esperienze però a
mio avviso c'è modo e modo nel senso che
l'esposizione sicuramente c'è
sicuramente ci sono dei compromessi che
debba vivere ma io ho sempre detto casa
come dicevo appunto è un luogo reale un
luogo fatto di persone o luogo non
perfetto un monologo vero ti faccio
l'ultima domanda che è proiettata al
futuro
tu sei insomma una delle figure di
riferimento per il mondo dei festival
dove sta andando questo mondo cioè cosa
si aspettavano secondo te le persone
indomani dei festival e cosa ti aspetti
tu nel senso quali sono i messaggi su
cui secondo te il mondo di cui fai parte
può lavorare per cercare di cambiare le
cose perché sente che è importante in
quel in quell'ambito in quel campo
cambiare le cose
noi lavoriamo con la fine col
divertimento nel senso che una delle
dei momenti in cui le persone si aprono
e dedicano più a loro stesse oppure al
fatto di essere di aggregarsi e diciamo
dal punto di vista sociale è uno dei
momenti di picco che una persona può
vivere il mondo dei testi ma dove sta
andando il mondo del festival sarà
sempre più presente noi siamo stati
degli innovatori in tale perché siamo
stati tra i primi a provare anche se con
un percorso abbastanza lungo perché
dovevamo abituare le persone a quello
che era un festival che non doveva
essere qualcosa è calato dall'alto ma
doveva essere qualcosa che appunto
avesse messo le radici
quindi le radici che poi ci portano
verso un futuro verso un futuro che ora
tutti quanti proveranno a dare cosa
proveranno a dare delle esperienze è
quello che mi auguri e che magari fra le
tante persone che partecipano un
festival magari tra cui tante persone ci
sia un altro non so se da una provincia
di un paese africano piuttosto che un
altro da dal sud del mondo dal sud
italia che magari viva la stessa
emozione che ho provato io è che poi ha
fatto sì che che costruisci questa casa
e allora per finire con una canzone
sono sicuro che il meglio debba ancora
venire
[Applauso]